in this video we're going to try to
compute
what tangent of 13 pi
over 12 is without using a calculator
but i will give you a few hints first of
all
you can rewrite tangent of 13 pi over 12
as
tangent of instead of 13 pi
over 12 we can express that in terms of
angles where we might be able to figure
out the tangents just based on
other things we know about the unit
circle 13 pi over 12 is the same thing
as 15 pi
over 12 minus 2 pi
over 12 which is the same thing as
the tangent of
5 pi over 4
minus pi over 6
or we could even view it as plus
negative pi over 6.
so that's my hint right over there so
pause this video and see if you can
keep going with this train of reasoning
to evaluate what tangent of 13 pi over
12 is without using a calculator
all right now let's keep on going
together
well we already know what the tangent of
the sum of
two angles are we've proven that in
another video
we know that this is going to be equal
to the tangent
of the first of these angles 5 pi
over 4 plus the tangent of the second
angle
tangent of negative pi
over 6 all of that is going to be over
1 minus tangent of the first angle
5 pi over 4
times the tangent of the second angle
negative pi over 6. and so now we can
break out our unit circles to figure out
what these things are
so i have pre-put some unit circles here
and so let's first think about what 5 pi
over 4 looks like
pi over 4 you might already associate it
with 45 degrees that's
pi over 4 right over there 2 pi over 4
would get you here 3 pi over 4s would
get you there
4 pi's over 4 which the same thing as pi
gets us over there 5 pi
over 4 would get us right right
about there now you might already
recognize the tangent of an
angle as the slope of the radius
and so this you might already be able to
intuit that the tangent here is going to
be one
but we can also break out our knowledge
of triangles and the unit circle to
figure this out if you didn't realize
that
so what we need to do is figure out the
coordinates of that point right over
there
and to help us do that we can set up a
little bit of a right triangle
which you might immediately recognize is
a 45-45-90 triangle how do i know that
well 5 pi over 4 remember we go 4 pi
over 4 to get here then we have one more
pi
over 4 to go down here so this angle
right over here is pi
over 4 or you could view it as 45
degrees and of course if that's 45
degrees that's 90 then this has to be 45
degrees because they all add up to
180 degrees and we know a triangle like
this
by the pythagorean theorem if our
hypotenuse is 1
each of the other two sides is square
root of 2 over 2
times the hypotenuse so this is square
root of 2 over 2 and then this is square
root of 2 over 2.
now if we think about the coordinates
our x coordinate is square root of 2
over 2 in the negative direction so our
x coordinate is negative
square root of 2 over 2 and our y
coordinate is square root of 2 over 2
going down so that's also negative
square root of 2
over 2. and the tangent is just the
y-coordinate over the x-coordinate here
so the tangent is just going to be
negative square root of 2 over 2 over
negative square root of 2 over 2 which
is once again
1 which was our intuition so we can
write that tangent
of 5 pi over 4
is equal to 1. and then what about
negative pi
over 6 well negative pi over 6 you might
recognize pi over 6
as being a 30 degree angle pi is 180
degrees so divided by 6 is 30 degrees
and negative pi over 6 would be going 30
degrees below the positive x-axis
so it would look just like that and as
we said this angle right over here is pi
over 6
which you can also view as a 30 degree
angle
if we were to drop a perpendicular right
over here
you might immediately recognize this as
a 30
60 90 triangle we know
if the hypotenuse is of length 1 the
side opposite the 30 degree side is
one half the hypotenuse and then the
longer non-hypotenuse side is going to
be square root of three times the
shorter side so square root of three
over two and so our coordinates right
over here
we are moving square root of 3 over 2 in
the positive x direction
square root of 3 over 2 and then we are
going negative one half
in the y direction so we put negative
one half
right over there and so now we know that
the tangent
of negative pi over 6
is going to be equal to negative
one-half
over square root of 3 over 2 which
is the same thing as negative one-half
times let me write it this way negative
one-half
times two over the square root of three
which is equal to negative one over the
square root of three
this right over here is one we saw that
there this right over here
is 1 and then this right over here
is negative 1 over the square root of 3
and then this is negative 1 over the
square root of 3. and so i can rewrite
this entire expression
as being equal to 1
minus 1 over the square root of 3
all of that over 1 and then i have a
negative here negative here so then that
becomes a negative times a negative so
positive
1 plus 1 over the square root of 3
and if we multiply both the numerator
and the denominator by square root
of 3 what we're going to get in the
numerator is
square root of 3 minus 1 and then our
denominator is going to be
square root of 3 plus 1 and
we are done that's tangent of 13 pi
over 12 without using a calculator